these massive flows place of s burden on
our healthcare system for doing a global
pandemic they threatened to create a
perfect storm that would spread the
infection to our border agents migrants
and to the public at large left
unchecked this would our
immigration system overwhelm our health
care system and severely damaged our
national security we're not going to let
that happen yes
president Trump closing the us-mexico
border to fight coronavirus remember
when people said you couldn't close the
border I guess they were wrong allowing
only essential travel and of course
trade now we warned you earlier this
week about a potential nightmare
unfolding at our southern border and now
it's even more urgent in the last week
the number of confirmed cases in Mexico
cut quadrupled from about 40 to more
than 160 and that's only what the
official stats tell us the Mexican
government doesn't seem to care much at
all why they did closed public schools
there are no travel restrictions and
only limited screenings of any travelers
and large gatherings concerts and so
forth are still happening now what you
have here are the ingredients a lot of
the epidemiologists are saying for an
epic disaster now here's how one of
Mexico's top epidemiologists put it from
my perspective we have all the
conditions for this to turn into a
tragedy similar to Italy if not worse so
now imagine what would happen at our own
border if Mexico overtook Italy as the
deadly hot spot for kovat 19 acting DHS
secretary Chad Wolfe painted a pretty
dire picture earlier today the outbreak
on our southern border would likely
increase the strain on health systems
and our border communities taken away
important and life-saving resources from
American citizens joining me now is
acting CBP commissioner mark Morgan
Christian Morgan the border is closing
but does that mean enforcement is
enhanced and more boots around the
ground how is how are we quote closing
the border and places where I was I mean
it's pretty desolate so all that has
happened but below I I do think words
matter
so because it means something different
to certain people so we're really not
closing the border as you just said
you're in your opening we're absolutely
limited and and taking reasonable
restrictions to contain and mitigate but
it's still going to be open to essential
travel and a cargo commercial trade is
going to continue to flow but this
president the this is the first time
that this has ever happened that we've
taken these authorities and applied them
and we're doing it both at the northern
border and the southern border again
this is bold aggressive action but it's
yet common sense and it's exactly what
we need to do well mark we've talked
about this before and where of course
we're not talking about the normal
entrant entry points into the country
where people have to you know meet a
Border Patrol official a customs
official we're not talking about that
we're talking about people who just you
know walk across the border a little
fence where that we don't have the wall
yet or people who float across the Rio
Grande now let me just understand this
because when we were in Del Rio last
year people were floating the Rio Grande
and it was very narrow and the places we
were and shallow in some places but
still water moves they were just turning
themselves into Border Patrol and then
getting bused to a different part of
Texas and then ultimately released into
the country I understand that we've also
gotten rid of or suspended all asylum
applications in between ports of entry
is that correct Lord your apps are a
that's the game changer and that's the
bold address of action that this
president took today and announced with
the CDC order what they have said is is
that exactly what you've been saying and
Lord we've been part of the task force
from day one and we've been talking with
CDC and the other health care providers
and today they gave the final order that
allows CBP to do just what you described
now when that when they enter illegally
we don't know anything about him they
have no documentation we don't know
anything about their mission ever now
it's not taking them in yeah I'm just
yeah we should never have taken them in
I mean the point is this is what we saw
when we were there but
want to remind everyone the reason that
these family units could come by the
thousands into the United States into
you knows crossing the Rio Grande walked
route and being released is because the
Trump administration was sued it's in
liberal judges put in injunctions
stopping the administration from sending
people immediately immediately but back
correct so that was liberal judges who
at the time were endangering our health
security and just our school resources
and everything else so this is something
the Trump administration has tried to do
before and judges stopped them but now
suddenly everyone's a border Hawk
because they're like well my life might
be in jeopardy now well or you're spot
on and and this is another look today
right now this is not about immigration
what this is about is borders matter
though and that's what we're seeing
right now so the unprecedented bold
actor this president has taken is first
and foremost because it's a health care
crisis and we need to protect first for
me I want to protect the men and women
CBP and the American people and with
this bold action the immigrants
themselves are actually going to be
protected as well so now once they come
across illegally the minute one of the
CBP now the authority we're turning
around right there and return him to
Mexico you like the word bold mark he's
a bold very bold it is bold but I mean
it was bold last year when the
administration did this
I mean they've tried to stop this
nonsense a year ago and again Trump was
way ahead of the curve on this border
problem and and now all these other
people are coming along to the view
however Commissioner Morgan Joe Biden
just eight days ago was tweeting this he
said a wall will not stop the corona
virus banning all travel from Europe or
any part of the world will not stop it
this disease could impact every nation
any person on the planet we need a plan
to combat it so Joe Biden wouldn't have
done any of this so we would have had
more people flooding in from affected
areas Laura just nine months in just
nine months at a thirty day period
because of the tactics that we've taken
and again I'll say it because of the
bold action this president has taken
drinking game
single month right it is single month
we've reduced that flow by a hundred
thousand that's a right now and in this
panic that we're in this health crisis
that's a hundred thousand less
individuals that would have been
illegally in in our country that is
absolutely a game-changer and the wall
is a part of that yeah well we need all
of that and this this has to be a lesson
for going forward we don't need TB
coming into the country we don't need
our schools to I mean that these people
were losing their jobs all over the
country they we don't need a flood of
new workers into America okay we need
people back to work as soon as medically
possible as soon as it's okay
health-wise Commissioner Morgan great to
see you stay safe out there and all our
love to the Border Patrol they're
amazing people I had a chance to meet so
many of them over the last several years
you take care